Jimmy and Michael here at CES 2018 we're
at razor's suite and razor always shows
off a bunch of weird kooky concepts at
CES and this year is no different
Michael can tell us what we're looking
at here right here is project Linda
which acts as a dock for the razor phone
it does a couple different things it
mirrors exactly what's happening on your
razor phone and it also has some
internals as well all the power is
driven from the razor phone so there
aren't any processors or GPUs in project
Linda itself but it does have internal
storage up to 250 gigabytes and it's a
1080p display 60 Hertz now I know the
razor phone itself is a 1440p display
with 200 up 220 Hertz they are working
on that they're trying to get that to
work but like I said aren't any power
internals inside of the project Linda
itself but it does have internal storage
and as a keyboard obviously as you can
see it also has USB ports so you can
plug in mice into project Linda itself
and the phone will recognize that so you
can use an external mouse because the
phone also acts as the trackpad it
doesn't feel the best based off of our
testing of project Landers yeah I think
it offers a little bit more resistance
than what you're used to it's nice it's
not quite as smooth yeah so it's like
flipping through your phone it's not
ideal for actual like computing there's
a couple smart designs to it too like
you can use the fingerprint reader the
fingerprint unlock here there's open
space free dip like put your thumb there
and you know thankfully the the phone
has like awesome speakers so but
basically this device just leverages is
that it kind of comes together in like a
nice sort of package and this is like
the first time that I've really seen a
major Android laptop I think most
laptops from like they use Google OS use
like Chrome or some idea so this is kind
of interesting you know whether or not
it actually comes out you know like time
will tell but you know what are your
impressions if it's at four I think it's
a neat idea out of all the crazy things
that we see out of Razer throughout the
years of CES I think this is one of the
more practical things that I've seen
yeah I mean again who knows if this will
come out there's no like release date or
anything but I mean from a practicality
standpoint I mean this is something that
has an internal battery
you can when when you dock your phone
into it it actually charges it it can
charge it three times over the OS is
like Android OS is actually pretty
smooth with like moving things over
opening apps and like navigating the OS
itself it's uh it feels like it so this
is an actual laptop that works you know
to see it and test it out and mess
around with those limited set of
features it has now this is like
something that can actually be used it's
not like this unwieldy thing that we've
seen in years past
right yeah razors like added a extra
skin that kind of makes it look a little
bit like Windows a little bit and I can
see this device being used to like
bolster productivity but it can also use
you know be used to bolster like Android
games as well whether or not like
Android games really pick up you know
major steam in this type of form factors
you know remains to be seen but I would
agree with you and say that this is
probably the most tangible concept from
razor you know you know at CES in a long
while for more CES coverage head on over
to GameSpot comm thanks for watching
[Music]